so big headlines were made over the last
24 hours
about Donald Trump saying he will
strongly consider testifying in his own
impeachment inquiry hearings and I'm
here to tell you no he will not even if
Donald Trump actually wants to we don't
know if he does
he said that he does that he'd be open
to it but it doesn't really matter
whether it's the truth or not
Donald Trump's lawyers are not going to
let him testify in his impeachment
hearings just like they wouldn't let him
talk to Robert Muller Trump yesterday
out of the hospital and tweeting quote
our crazy do nothing where's us MCA
infrastructure lower drug pricing and
much more Speaker of the House
nervous Nancy Pelosi who is petrified by
her radical left knowing she will soon
be gone they in fake news media are her
boss but look at the number of
parentheticals here suggested on Sundays
d Face the Nation that I testify about
the phony impeachment witch-hunt she
also said I could do it in writing even
though I did nothing wrong and don't
like giving credibility to this no due
process hoax
I like the idea and will in order to get
Congress focused again strongly consider
it meaning testifying no he won't
this is all a response to what Trump is
saying Nancy Pelosi told CBS's Face the
Nation on Sunday which is that the
president could come right before the
committee and talk to us he could speak
all the truth he wants if that's what he
wants to do but Trump is not going to be
testifying I would bet money on it and I
don't bet the idea again is project
strength project the idea that trumps
not afraid to testify to try to give his
followers ammunition to say look Trump
is willing to testify what about the
whistleblower
why won't they give Donald Trump due
process but Donald Trump will not
testify this is all a charade no matter
what Donald Trump is actually thinking
about testifying he is not going to and
it's actually both funny and sad in the
way that tragic downfalls of our
institutions can be funny we have an
impeachment inquiry into the President
of the United States he says he will
consider testifying we all know he will
never test
two-five because he would instantly
perjure himself he would immediately
self-incriminate and still 40% of the
country thinks everything is fine and
normal and they approve of the job that
Donald Trump is doing now people are
talking about Trump should be forced to
testify and then the reaction is oh no
we have a Fifth Amendment so Donald
Trump cannot be forced to testify in a
case against him this is actually a very
interesting legal question and there's a
good counter-argument because you might
say yeah you you simply can't force
someone to testify in a proceeding that
is investigating them the Fifth
Amendment definitely applies for
something where Trump is criminally
liable but remember that this is an
impeachment inquiry this is about
whether Donald Trump abused power
engaged in bribery or extortion it's not
necessarily a criminal proceeding and it
is not at its face a criminal proceeding
it could expose criminality so the
argument that I've been reading is that
Trump arguably does not have the right
to remain silent in what is a civil
impeachment proceeding now I don't know
that it's been litigated I'm sure that
if it got to courts it would tie them up
for a very long time but at least it's
not obvious that Donald Trump couldn't
be forced to testify in his own
impeachment inquiry we are once again in
uncharted waters but I don't believe
that it is going to happen the most
important takeaway here is do not expect
to see Donald Trump testifying period
and based on what we've been seeing
since Donald Trump last left the
hospital on Saturday
his public presence in general has been
extraordinarily limited I won't rehash
the story from earlier in the show but
it does not appear that we are getting
straight answers about what is currently
going on with Donald Trump's health I
have no particular theory about it it
just is pretty clear that the story
we're getting from the White House
doesn't make sense it is not the truth
and hopefully at some point we will hear
it how it will relate if at all to the
impeachment inquiry the extraordinarily
remote possibility of Donald Trump
testifying despite saying that he would
be conceivably interested in it we still
don't know but it is maybe something
that by the end of the week will we will
no more about tomorrow by the way
continued live coverage on the David
Pakman show YouTube channel during the
day of the impeachment inquiry hearings
and then at night we will switch over to
twitch where we will be live streaming
the democratic debate make sure you're
following me on instagram at david
pakman and follow the show on instagram
as well at david pakman show we'll take
a quick break we will have new polling
coming up and much much more
the David Pakman show is possible thanks
to sponsors like VIN Charo watches
giving everyone in our audience 15% off
your entire order when you go to david
pakman.com slash watch I just got a
couple of new watches from these guys
and I love them I got the Kairos limited
release gold reserve set which is very
cool I love the white face the simple
band and everything about it it's a
perfect size for my wrist really great
choice I also picked out the Ventura
bellwether
in silver and white and what I love
about this one number one the Roman
numeral at the top of the face the white
face is great this is a cronograph model
and I love the blue leather band it's
just a really nice looking watch
everybody who sees me wear this one
always asks about it what I like about
Vince arrow as a watch brand is you're
getting quality and you're getting a
watch where it's clear as soon as you
open the box that a lot of care and
artisanship went into the design and the
way that the watch is put together I'm
not interested in paying thousands of
dollars for a watch when I can get one
that's reasonably priced and looks just
as nice and has terrific build quality
and that's exactly what vince arrow is
in the business of doing putting a ton
of craftsmanship into their watches
making them available for a hundred and
fifty two hundred bucks you really can't
go wrong check them out at david
pakman.com slash watch support the
people who support our show and you'll
save fifteen percent when you use that
link